die mondmissionen der usa 2024 muss
ausfallen allerdings soll jetzt ihren
masken das schlägt die ehemalige vize
chefin der nasa lori garver vor
wir hatten ja exklusiv darüber berichtet
dass die mondmissionen gezwungenermaßen
ausfallen muss allerdings offiziell
abgesagt hat das unternehmen noch
niemand nur mit einer nicht
funktionierenden rakete einer kapsel die
noch keinen planmäßigen flug absolviert
hat und keine mond länder für dessen
entwicklung zudem die finanziellen
mittel zusammengestrichen worden sind
kann es einfach nicht klappen ist also
ihren mast mit spacex die rettung klicks
und tanz im flugzeug jetzt dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen so langsam zeigt
sich ähnlich wie in der autobranche
krempelt auch mast mit spacex traumfahrt
um seine idee raketen wiederzuverwenden
macht raketenstart zu einem schnäppchen
und nur deshalb ist auch in der lage in
einem immer schnelleren rhythmus star
links satelliten auf eigene rechnung ins
all zu schießen inzwischen sind bereits
mehr als 1000 satelliten im orbit und
das system hat erfolgreich den beta
betrieb aufgenommen
vielen macht hat also beim space race
2.0 die nase vorn das diskutieren wir
übrigens hier auf dem kanal live mit dem
esa generaldirektor josef aschbacher der
astronauten kandidatin ins aktive reicht
dem europaabgeordneten niklas ninas von
den grünen und mir und ihr könnt sogar
live in der konferenz dabei sahen hier
unter me könnt ihr euch anmelden
der start einer falcon 9 rakete von
spacex kostet nur rund 60 millionen
dollar der start einer europäischen
ariane 5 dagegen 170 millionen dollar
das ist rund das dreifache allerdings
kann die ariane rund 50 prozent mehr
fracht ins all transportieren
dieser vorteil wird allerdings von der
falcon heavy kassiert sie kann mit 45
tonnen in den low earth orbit das
doppelte der ariane 5 ins all bringt bei
etwa den gleichen kosten wie eine ariane
5 sprich nur noch russland und china
können in diesem preisbereich knapp
konkurrieren und dann gibt es ja noch
das starship und mit dem
spacex nicht nur 60 satelliten pro start
in den weltraum bringen sondern 400 und
2023 will maske mond zum ersten mal mit
chip umrunden und das nicht mit
astronauten und astronautinnen sondern
mit privatleuten jeder und jeder kann
sich da übrigens bewerben der link ist
hier unter b
noch bis zum 14 märz kann man sich dort
registrieren also haut rein und wenn er
für die mission ausgewählt werden sag
mir bescheid den ganzen spaß bezahlt
übrigens der japanische milliardär kazuo
comesa war und er hat bedingungen egal
welche aktivität und nach gehst mit der
möglichkeit in den weltraum zu reißen
hoffe ich dass dies die entwicklung
seines schaffens vorantreibt um anderen
menschen und der breiten gesellschaft in
irgendeiner weise zu helfen bis zu
zufrieden mit dem was du gerade machst
kannst du mit der chance in den weltraum
zu fliegen sogar etwas besseres etwas
größeres vollbringen gut jetzt sind
mastzeit angaben immer in zweifel zu
ziehen pünktlich hat er glaube ich noch
nichts geschafft aber zumindest 2024
dann wenn die nasa eigentlich auf dem
mond landen wollte könnte er ihn mit
dieser mission umrunden denn bei der
nasa ist dieses ziel der artemis mission
in weite ferne gerückt wie wir hier
exklusiv berichtet haben das space
launch system sls die mondrakete wird
einfach nicht fertig und auch die orion
kapsel hat bei ihrem testflug im letzten
jahr die internationale raumstation iss
verfehlt während spacex mit der kuh
dragon und der falken rakete quasi den
regulären flugbetrieb zu ss aufgenommen
hat schafft die nasa nicht die selbst
gesteckten ziele
erst 2009 10 hat der ex nasa chef jim
wittenstein
das sls vorgestellt eine riesige rakete
und glaubt an ein zitat wichtiger
meilenstein und ein beweis für das
amerikanische unternehmertum und den
erfindergeist mit mehr als 1.100 großen
und kleinen unternehmen in 44 staaten
die zur konstruktion und montage
beitragen wird die sls rakete amerika
befähigen das ziel des artemis programms
zu erreichen
die erste frau und den nächsten mann bis
2024 auf dem mond zu landen
den bemannten erst flug zum mond steht
quasi nichts mehr im wege 2020 sollte
der orangefarbene gigant das erste mal
getestet werden und 2021 soll an orion
raumschiff um den mond ran
von tieren allerdings unbemannt ein
bemannter stadt sollte 2022 folgen für
das jahr 2024 war dann der große coup
der nasa geplant mehr als 51 jahre nach
der letzten mondlandung sollte dann also
auch eine frau teil der besatzung seien
65 meter hoch und damit so groß wie ein
20 stöckiges gebäude ist die super
rakete space launch system
doch nicht nur das ist ein rekord auch
ihre leistung übertrumpft alles nach
offiziellen nasa-angaben erreicht sie
eine rekord überschallgeschwindigkeit
von 823 also 23 fache
schallgeschwindigkeit umgerechnet sind
das 28 1400 kilometer pro stunde
diese geschwindigkeit soll sie erreichen
bis sie dann von der orion mannschafts
kapsel getrennt wird doch all diese
ehrgeizigen ziele sind nicht erreicht
worden
die rakete wird einfach nicht
einsatzbereit gerade erst am 16 januar
musste der achtminütige testlauf der
ersten stufe der ersten sls rakete die
staaten sollen nach 67 sekunden wegen
eines hydraulikproblems abgebrochen
werden sprich der erste staat der sls
der ja eigentlich schon 2020 stattfinden
sollte der wird wahrscheinlich nicht mal
2021 stattfinden können die rakete wird
einfach nicht einsatzbereit und das so
muss man festhalten dass die falcon
heavy bereits seit geraumer zeit
startklar ist und zudem für die reise
zum mond geeignet und das seit 2008 zehn
und die kosten laufen immer weiter aus
dem ruder und sie werden inzwischen
begrenzt das todesurteil für die mission
das budget für den länder die neue
mondfähre das human landing system alles
wurde auch ein viertel gekürzt und
währenddessen testet und testet space ex
sein starship eine noch stärkere geht
als defekten heavy und auch knapp
stärker als die sls und das starship
soll im erdorbit aufgetankt werden
können so dass es die fünffache turnage
zum mond bringen könnte und zudem ist
das starship auch ein länder und
benötigt keine separate landefähre lässt
gerade einen mond aufzug für das hohe
raumschiff entwickelt damit man aus der
rakete auf dem mond auch aussteigen kann
mit den problemen bei der sls und der
fortschreitenden entwicklung des stars
empfangen die fachleute den usa jetzt am
umzudenken zwar bewertet die nasa noch
die aktuellen entwicklungen bis mai aber
das ergebnis ist
jetzt schon klar die ehemalige nasa
vize-chefin lori garver hat es jetzt
erstmals so deutlich gesagt dass sls
raumschiff seien veraltet und eben nicht
wieder verwendbar wie die space extra
geben und deshalb sehr teuer und zudem
sogar war während zwar die zeitpläne von
ihnen macht auch eher optimistisch aber
realistischer als die der nasa und wenn
es so weitergeht wird die entwicklung
des starship schon bald die entwicklung
des sls überholen und dann spreche
eigentlich gar nichts mehr gegen das
schild als raumschiff vor die
mondlandung den usa einen mast sollte
dann die raumfahrzeuge für die
mondlandung bereitstellen sogar war
wir hätten das schon vor langer zeit tun
sollen sogar was denn wenn es bei ihnen
macht so weiter geht der test als länder
ist ja gerade gelungen
dann wird er starship wahrscheinlich
deutlich schneller fertig bekommen als
die nasa das sls wenn die fortschritte
bei spacex sind massiv mit der landung
des stars prototypen sn 10 ist zum
ersten mal die obere stufe einer rakete
erfolgreich wieder auf der erdoberfläche
gelandet bei den ersten mondmissionen
wäre das also ein kinderspiel eine
landung auf dem mond zu absolvieren man
wieder zeigt es viele masken und eben
auch der gesamten raumfahrtindustrie
hier muss reagiert werden und das nicht
nur bei der nasa sondern auch bei der
europäischen raumfahrt agentur esa
darüber spreche ich mit esa
generaldirektor josef aschbacher der
astronautinnen kandidatin in satire euch
und dem europaabgeordneten niklas nicht
das von den grünen seid live dabei
hierauf clixoom schaut ab und zu mal in
den community tab für weitere infos und
ihr könnt auch direkt in der sohn
konferenz dabei sein und mitdiskutieren
einfach hier klicken anmelden und
mitdiskutieren ich freue mich auf euch
am 18 märz um 19 uhr
hierauf klicks bis dann bleibt dran